Defense mechanisms have two sets of
key characteristics that have important
consequences.
The first is the distinction
between constitutive and inducible,
and the second is the distinction
between innate and acquired.
Whether a defense mechanism
is constitutive or inducible
depends on its costs,
its deployment requirements,
and whether the hostile environmental
factors are present always occasionally or
only periodically.
Okay.
Most defenses are inducible on demand
because they cost a lot and they are
unnecessary or even detrimental
in the absence of the threat.
Yeah.
They fully satisfy the
functional criterion for
recognizing adaptations that we
discussed in the first lectures.
Yeah.
The cost of much of the immune system
energy immunopathology collateral tissue
damage are too high to allow
constitutive activation in the absence of
infection. This is something that you
only want to turn on when you need it.
Okay.
It's low cost components.
The secreted defensins and things like
immunoglobulin a are constitutive because
they do not damage Dimmitt tissue and
they don't cost very much so they can be
on all the time.
Yeah.
There were some issues
with inducing a defense.
Yeah.
When several defense mechanisms
can protect from a given challenge,
they should be induced in the
order of increasing costs.
For example,
avoidance is cheaper than repair.
Yeah.
And anticipatory responses can be
induced for challenges that occur with
predictable periodicity.
For example,
the seasons or upon detecting a proxy
that signals immediate presence.
Yeah.
For example,
starvation in the womb and to neonates
alters metabolism for years for the
developing brain, but creating
risks for late life, diabetes,
obesity and cardiovascular disease.
We saw that with Dohad,
the developmental origins
of health and disease.
This is an anticipatory response.
Okay.
There's some other features of
induction or misses and a climatization.
Innate defenses can be adjusted to the
environment by individual experience,
a secondary exposure to the
same noxious factor results.
Then in a more efficient
and a more rapid response.
This process is called hormesis.
So for example,
exposure to a low level of a toxin can
induce expression of detoxification
genes,
so that subsequent exposure to
otherwise lethal doses can be tolerated.
This is something that every culture
has used poisons to kill people he has
known about. It's one of the ways to
defend one's self against poisoning.
And it figures prominently in the case
of Valentine to via fort in the count of
Monte Cristo.
Okay.
Or misses is related to a climatization,
but the two off usually operate
on different timescales.
The term hormesis is usually applied
to a discrete environmental exposure.
For example, a dose of toxin. Well,
a climatization is usually applied
to continuous exposures. For example,
changes in temperature, humidity,
oxygen, tension, things like that.
So here is a figure of Dumont.
Uh,
talking to Valentine,
he gave her small doe anticipating that
she would be the object of a poisoning
attempt.
He gave her small doses of the poison
and when she was actually poisoned in the
novel,
she went into a coma and recovered.
So that's an example of four nieces.
Yeah.
Now what about the reversibility of
defenses and the timescales on which that
can be done?
Most inducible mechanisms are reversible
and they do operate on different
timescales.
Rapid physiological adaptation operates
on the scale of seconds to minutes.
So that would be hyperventilation,
shivering, increased heart rate,
all methods of dealing
with temperature change.
My policies,
gluconeogenesis in the immune response
operate on the scale of hours to days.
Yeah.
The climatization operates on the scale
of days to weeks, months, and years.
It can take quite a while to get
used to walking at high altitude.
Yeah,
and developmental plasticity is an often
irreversible form of adaptation that is
usually induced at an early developmental
stage and then it lasts for a lifetime.
Yeah.
So we have seen this diagram before and
it lays out the idea that physiological
adaptation is fast.
Acclimation is intermediate.
Elite mental plasticity is
slow and often irreversible.
There are important distinctions
between immune and behavioral defenses.
Defenses that are mediated by the immune
in the nervous system have two distinct
components,
innate and acquired.
So this is actually a similarity,
both of them in some sense,
learn, acquired, and learn.
Defenses are very flexible and they
can be adjusted to unpredictable
environments.
So if you don't know what kind of
environment is going to be encountered,
it would be good to have a system designed
that can learn to deal with anything
that comes along and the kinds of things
that are unpredictable or pathogens.
Predators, toxic plants, venomous insects.
We need methods of dealing
with all of those things.
Yeah.
Adaptive and acquired systems
also have the benefit of memory.
We have both neurological memory
and we have immune memory.
Yeah.
The immune system thus resembles the
nervous system in some important ways.
We also know that the two systems can
communicate with each other to share
information on the environment.
There is crosstalk between the immune
system and the central nervous system.
Flint,
this kind of flexibility has benefits,
but it also has costs.
Although most invertebrates rely for
defense on innate immunity in behavior,
whereas vertebrates used both innate and
adaptive acquired immunity and behavior.
Yeah.
Why adaptive systems evolved
in vertebrates is not
completely clear for they are
impressively risky.
Although the adaptive systems of
vertebrates provide clear advantages.
They also create vulnerabilities to
disease that are absent in invertebrates.
These vulnerabilities include
autoimmune and allergic diseases,
mental diseases and behavioral
abnormalities such as
severe obsessive compulsive
disorder, paranoia and phobia.
The costs of flexibility,
those include risks of
new types of disease.
The point being made here is that one
does not often see a mentally deranged
honeybee or a mentally deranged octopus.
Those kinds of vulnerabilities are
consequences of the flexibility and
complexity of our adaptive
behavioral system.
And they resembled the vulnerabilities
that we have in our adaptive immune
system.
Yeah.
So here's a guy with paranoia and here
are some lesions in the central nervous
system.
Yeah,
so benefits and costs of homeostasis.
Homeostasis is overall a good thing.
It keeps the internal
environment constant,
but the mechanisms that produce
it contained vulnerabilities.
The idea of law called Stoltz do media
and [inaudible] comes from Claude
Bernard, the great 19th
century French physiologist,
and
he saw the internal
regulation was important.
It is done with systems that
have multiple set points,
so they are Rio static.
They can be set to different
levels of concentration,
different levels of temperature.
And that is one of the ways
that they are flexible,
but those are also set
points that can be broken.
So that is how we evolve to optimize
or adaptation to varying needs and
environments.
A single set point system is
resistant to dysregulation,
but it does not lead to
a disease of homeostasis.
But if you have multiple set points is,
for example, with our blood sugar levels,
they are vulnerable to dysregulation
and they permit then the diseases of
homeostasis,
the same mechanisms that evolve to
change the set points with adaptive
consequences.
Those permit dysregulation in disease
such diseases include type two diabetes,
gout,
and some types of obesity here
illustrated for Gout and obesity.
Some of the features of
these systems are redundancy,
compensation and compatibility,
and it's worth taking a minute
or two to distinguish among them.
Most defenses have multiple components.
Who's deployment is coordinated and it
unfolds in order of increasing cost.
The components can compensate for each
other when one is damaged in that makes
the system robust and efficient.
Okay.
However,
the intact components also have to
operate at higher magnitude or for longer
duration,
and that can result in immunopathology.
So if one part of the system is
knocked out and another compensates,
it can overcompensate.
Compatible defenses are ones that
neither cooperate nor interfere.
Yeah.
Synergistic defenses or defenses that
cooperate and incompatible defenses
interfere with each other.
So for example,
inflammation is incompatible with
detoxification and cold adaptation and an
immune defense, or both incompatible
with the starvation response.
Okay.
So in thinking about defenses,
it's wise to keep in mind
these issues of redundancy,
compensation and compatibility because
they are all involved in the diseases of
defense.
Yeah.
So to summarize, defenses are
inducible when they are costly.
Yeah.
Redundant defenses are induced
in order of increasing costs.
[inaudible] occurs when a first exposure
to a threat induces defenses that make
leader exposures less harmful
and we're rapidly dealt with.
Yeah.
Induction of defenses takes time.
It can take from seconds to months,
depending upon the factor
in the type of defense.
Adaptive and acquired defenses have
the benefits of flexibility and memory,
but those also make us vulnerable
to new types of diseases.